we have something I'm nervous about
what's about to happen
uh we have something a bit different
today to start the show because my
producers like to just mess with me
um which is love right
um and because we're all fans of the old
Rosie O'Donnell show I love Rosie Show
um we're trying yeah
um we are trying something new this is
called
[Music]
[Applause]
new phone who it is that's funny
um the rules are and well we're learning
these together because I'm reading this
from the prompter like Ron Burgundy uh
because I have no idea what's about to
happen so rules are someone is about to
call in
and without looking I'll have to guess
who it is
in four questions or less what
okay oh and there's the call
okay there's the call
oh hello
yeah
oh wait I can you hear me
I can hear you fine
wait are they trying to distract their
I'm trying to I was trying to okay okay
I'm about to turn around and in a moment
where we'll fill your face to the
audience and people at home uh then I'll
have four questions to guess who you are
here we go okay
um okay Joe um you can reveal our secret
color to the audience because I can't
see
so
[Music]
everyone is very excited okay okay okay
oh everyone is very excited okay okay
are you I mean it's this show are you an
actor
what a dumb question
oh wow
I think that sounds like someone I know
but I don't know if that okay okay then
you're a musician
are you a musician yeah
yeah about right
that was Beetlejuice
[Applause]
okay at first I thought it was Niall
Horan and then I was like No wait it's
like not because I thought I heard an
accent but like I didn't
um okay uh
I mean so then that leads me to leave
but are they maybe like being okay are
you were you were you Beetlejuice
no I've never been Beetle two step it
will be
never will be
um
oh my God
I I know okay they they said musician
hold on I have one more question so hold
on I'm
I know a musician yes
who kind of sounds Irish like but also
British like I'm like I so I'm like I
don't know like
I'm like oh wait okay let's Okay okay
last question
um this was really no prep for this so
um okay
um
are you I don't have a question how do
you not how do you attempt this with one
question
um uh are are you want me to give you a
hint
now it sounded like a completely
different accent okay yes I would like a
hint
and my nickname they call me Mr Yearwood
[Laughter]
oh my God you did such a great job at
accents that's good
[Applause]
[Music]
I was I was like what
oh my God hello
oh my God I'm so glad I'm on this end
and not on that end oh my God that's
horrible can I tell you
I was gonna have to come up with the
questions until just now
and I was like what and I was like what
question and then you sit on it like
Beetlejuice and so I was like and then
Irish at one point I feel like and then
British and then I was like you're
American I was like anyway so what are
you doing here
I am going to ask a favor from a
neighbor if uh you don't mind we
announce that we are going to do a
residency in Las Vegas
[Applause]
so excited wait so you I'm so excited
about that wait you have a new box set
as well right
yeah well you know as as we put these
tickets on uh for Christmas presents and
anytime you get tickets for a Christmas
presents you kind of sit there with them
and nothing really to open so what the
what the guys at Caesars wanted to do
which I thought was pretty cool was put
together a box set solely for Caesars
the only place you can get it you'll
have to get tickets to get it it can be
like a retail store you can just uh kind
of get them online and then get it or
you can get it with your tickets either
way what I love about this is you talk
about live live live which Caesars is
going to be this is going to be every
kind of different version of live that
we have
um what's the format of the show what's
what's different about this one yes so
you remember the one-man show it's just
me and a guitar this is called Garth
plus one okay so this is what's cool
we're taking the whole band with us but
the whole band sits with the audience
and if you just want to pull up a fiddle
player for a song fiddle player just
comes up if you just want to pull up
percussion and background vocals for the
river that's all you do or if you want
to bring the whole band up for a call on
Baton Rouge Your Friends in Low Places
then you get to do the muscle thing and
it's uh so what I'm going to love about
this is it's going to be 8 000 shows in
two hours and that's that's Vegas that's
Garth and that sounds like a lot of fun
to me it's a whole a lot of fun I'm so
excited oh my gosh I love seeing you
I've seen you do huge shows I've seen
you do intimate things it's incredible
that you're capable of both in killing
it in every Arena that you're in and
every setting I'm no BS I'm so excited
about coming to see it Garth Brooks
ascending to Vegas in 2023 everybody
good
Las Vegas to register for tickets and
Order guard
City box set if you're smart
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]